no touching no contact in Sunday Mass
services all over the Philippines Asia's
only predominantly Roman Catholic
country common practices such as holding
hands while singing in pray or offering
one's cheek to another as a sign of
peace
are discouraged because of the
coronavirus risk it's a big concern for
us because here in the Philippines and
people congregate together in our
religious services and a lot of people
come together especially during this
time of length all over Asia governments
are increasingly limiting gatherings of
large crowds in some places schools are
closed public events cancelled in South
Korea where the corona virus outbreak is
suspected to have originated in a
religious meeting Catholic Church has
suspended Sunday services for the first
time in more than 200 years on the
Korean Peninsula that isn't necessary
yet in the Philippines sassed Catholic
leadership but empty pews are no longer
a rare sight in some churches this
church in Manila Chinatown is usually
full on Sundays with people sometimes
having to stand right by entrances but
for weeks now many churchgoers in this
community have not been attending Mass
as a precaution against the corona virus
outbreak those who opted not to go to
church however are finding other ways to
fulfill their spiritual needs Carlo
Ponti Han now watches a Sunday worship
online instead of going to church
a lot of people would say oh yeah you're
getting sick just pray about it right
but it's even in our church we would say
you still have to go to a doctor right
so it doesn't mean that if you have
faith it's everything that you should
just stand on you have to have faith but
you also have to act on on your faith
considering himself a devout Christian
he says skipping church shouldn't be
seen as compromising his faith
especially when is to protect family
members barnaby lo al jazeera Manila